وفي التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا افاد الجيش الاوكراني باستمرار
القصف الروسيه على مقاطع
قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه استمرار
القصف المدفعي المتبادل على طول ضفتين نهر
النيبرو في خرسون
ليله الماضيه 10 مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع
استاد فاتت مقاطعه
جنوبيه البلاد ويسجل بيانو سلاح الجو
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تشرين هجمات
على اهداف في الجنوب الاوكراني بمسيرات
ايرانيه من طراز شاهد 100 و361
افاد الجيش الاوكراني باستمرار القصف
الروسيه على مقاطع
البلاد وافاد مراسلنا نقلا عن الجيش
اللبناني ان القوات الروسيه نفذت خلال
الساعات الماضيه اكثر من 70 هجوما على قرن
وبلدات في خرسون اضافه الى استهدافه في
محطه
على خط التماسي في ذا فولوجيا وقرى في
نيكو بول في دنيترو في غضون ذلك اكدت
قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه استمرار
القصف المدفعيه المتبادل على طول نهر
النيل